so there's the setup let's see how well
number one my new monic device work the
number two how good your memory is what
are the four steps I have to go through
to prove this by induction you just
think you just won't be harder to taste
okay T a so the very first thing I need
to do is test for what value for the
first one mobile novice one right which
in this case I guess would be one right
okay so let's give this a go I'm
actually going to write out what I'm
doing rather than just have lines of the
rhythms name sir yes so I'm gonna say
test for what so here's my left-hand
side and the left-hand side is usually
pretty trivial right how many of these
tents aren't gonna have if I go up to
and sweat and it's just one so one okay
right hand side at least they don't
already yeah all the ends replaced with
ones okay so 1 over 6 1 plus 1 2 plus 1
Thank You Co 6 times 2 times 3 which is
1
okay next step a for soon right so I'm
gonna assume the statement is true for N
equals K which is so arbitrary number
right in other words I'm picking some
one of the dominoes any of the dominoes
really and then we'll look at the next
one okay
so I'll say I see your truth okay well I
do watch out we're using K a lot and if
you're like me when you're in a hurry
your k's you sort of write like this
right and then when you're writing
really faster turns into this which
turns into this and then you're like
wait you come from
okay so just because you're writing on
one case just to be a safe guard let's
go back to when 0n foundation is that
like prequel kindy okay
write your line down and then that's not
gonna that's not gonna turn into a hedge
I promise okay
unless you try really hard okay anyway
so there's my cape now please do it
right in the next scene right don't
write therefore okay because it's not
this is not logically therefore I can
imply something right there's no logic
behind I'm just it's I'm just making
assumption okay so don't put therefore
an it's not a yoga smart for it but it's
kind of when I'm reading something a
proof by induction because I know well
rather you know what you meant to end at
right there's no value on getting to the
answer because you've already got the
answer all of the value is amol so in
between right and and being on
demonstrate i understand how this proof
works and if you say therefore
so instead say I'm assuming it true for
this value what that means is what that
looks like is these values all the way
up to UK squared is equal to okay done
and now the work begins okay because P
stands for B stands for proof croup for
the next value okay so I'm gonna try and
use this
now be careful how you write this next
part right make it easy for yourself so
make the substitution the by assumptions
then okay so instead of going what's
going to spend 3 square plus and then
make the last term K plus 1 or square
that is the last term okay but what I
want to include the second last term as
well because then I've got this part
here which I can just swap out okay so
I'm gonna now prove okay possible so my
next line just to make it clearer for me
okay I say required to prove so then I
distinguish that from something I'm
saying is true versus something I've got
to actually establish right so I've got
1 squared 2 squared K plus 1 okay again
um beginners error please make sure the
K plus 1 that you stub in the whole
thing is being squared right it's very
simple and very common for people in a
rush to accidentally write instead of K
plus 1 all squared + K squared plus 1
that's the kind of error which we do and
we're rushed it's very difficult to spot
out by this is wrong because it looks ok
little cause you are doing problems
later on so don't do that I want to show
that that's equal to this but for K plus
1
okay now again it doesn't hurt to
actually put in here two times k plus 1
in brackets plus 1 I'm just trying to
save a little bit of space here but
every little arithmetic error counts and
a lot of the times when you ask for help
oh I have trouble right it's a lot a
problem in you know misunderstanding
this it's just some little thing like
this and you need to tear your hair out
trying to search for a solution which is
never going to work
all right so I'm going to start with the
left-hand side and get to the right the
left-hand side equals this I just write
it out there
and then sometimes even just to make it
clear for me right I identified another
color the part that I can substitute
with the UM with the inductive statement
or by assumption right so this is the
part that I can substitute out okay you
already careful with somebody telling
them to give you later on or you might
have seen it's not just the first number
of terms sometimes there's a turn at the
front which isn't included okay but it
doesn't belong here so just be very
watchful for what you're actually
substituting okay that we're assuming is
equal to this
okay so there's my trigger step step now
I just have to do our Darrell now as
we're before when you did like say trig
identities or even when you're trying to
prove because this is what I'm thinking
about for your xi you've got to prove a
front in this bowl of proof functions
even we're used to taking this anything
any algebraic statement and just
simplify it down as far as we can go
okay but we don't actually want to
simplify as far as we can go we want to
get to a specific point and that might
not be the simplest it can be okay so
what I'm gonna do is before I do any
work in keep my eyes on the target
highlight it you know this is where I've
got to go and think what's the shortest
path I can take to get there so for
instance I can see I've got a K plus 1
and a K plus 1 here which I want to have
at the front right so I'm not going to
do any expansions or anything like that
even though I'm sure some of the terms
will cancel out that's not going to help
me it's gonna get me further away from
my goal rather than closer okay so I'm
gonna factorize by K plus 1 and head out
the front so you can see here what I've
done is change the order to make it more
obvious that I'm going in this direction
okay now this guy here I can't quite get
it like that I've got to multiply by
something to get this on six right so
I'm gonna go six k plus one all squared
on six very real change but just to make
it easier to see what my factorization
will be okay so now I've got my common
factor out the front I've got K plus 1 6
and then what's on the side well here
I'll have this and then over here
what'll I have 6 lots of
all right I'm always there right this
pile out the front I don't need to touch
at all because I know it's right okay
and this bidding see I just need to
expand and hopefully if I haven't done
any algebra slip-ups it should all look
good k plus one on six collect your like
terms okay now this is what my hating
things about this being a trip by
induction because we already know where
we trying to end up you can use some
creative license to get from here I find
it I think it's not a leap to go
straight to here because that's just a
good factorization you don't need to get
out like quadratic form or anything like
that if you're good a factorizing you
can see that straight away I'm not so
it's sort of if I got this and you ask
me factorize if I take a second to get
there but you already know where you
going to go through okay and there's no
intermediate steps if you if you were
factorizing so okay plus one on six out
front and okay again let me stress I
think that's a legitimate transition to
me because what would you put in there
like what other lines would you permit
to make it clearer I think they're okay
that's equal to my right hand side and
rather space sorry
so I've finished step three what's my
last step what's the e for I just have
to explain
which as we saw before and these days
doesn't take much all I have to do
underneath all of this is say by the
principle of mathematical induction
which is what we've been using well the
principle of mathematical induction the
statements true and the last thing you
just have to be careful for is what
values it's true for okay so some of the
examples I'm going to give you later
today if we get there for things like
divisibility they often true only for
certain values and up here we're just N
equals 1 sorry for N equals 1/2